[Musique]
thomas bonjour alors le gouvernement
pourrait-il effectivement décidé de nous
re confirmé mais c'est une hypothèse qui
n'est pas exclue a indiqué hier olivier
véran le ministre de la santé affirme
suivre l'évolution de la situation heure
par heure est selon lui la situation
devrait s'aggraver dans les prochains
jours on est encore loin de la barre
fatidique des 5 milles contamination
quotidienne qui avait été décrétée par
le gouvernement afin de lever certaines
restrictions alors du côté de l'exécutif
on n'écarte aucune piste vous l'avez dit
un conseil de défense aura lieu ce mardi
par visioconférence pour l'heure rien
n'indique qu'un nouveau confinement
nationale sera décidé mais c'est une
option fortement recommandée par un
certain nombre de spécialistes
une autre hypothèse serait de mettre en
place des confinement locaux dans des
régions particulièrement touchées par
l'épidémie on pense notamment à la
région grand-est ces derniers jours des
maires de la région ont appelé à des
mesures locales le 22 décembre le maire
de nancy avait indiqué qu'il souhaitait
un confinement juste après noël
et pour justifier sa demande mathieu
klein met en avant le taux d'incidence
dans sa ville il est passé de 108 cas
positifs au kovy 19 pour cent mille
habitants le 3 décembre à 258 lundi 21
décembre selon le maire d'autres voix
ont fait part de leurs inquiétudes dans
la région un grand test qui avait déjà
été fortement impactée par la première
vague au printemps dernier écoutez ce
qu'en dit le maire de colmar il appelle
pour sa part à des mesures très ciblées
localement lorsqu'on parle de
confinement à l'échelle des régions
je n'y suis pas favorable il faut aller
plus dans le détail airs confiné à
l'échelle des départements à l'intérieur
des grandes régions il y à des
disparités très fortes d'un département
à l'autre les autres arbitrages attendus
ces prochains jours par le gouvernement
il ya là la question aussi dès la
réouverture des lieux culturels liés à
ce stade rien n'a été tranché le
gouvernement se laisse un peu de temps
initialement la date du 7 janvier avait
été avancée pour la réouverture des
lieux culturels mais là encore le
gouvernement pourrait décider de tout
reporter en raison
des indicateurs sanitaires d'ailleurs la
ministre de la culture parle maintenant
du 7 janvier comme d'une clause de
revoyure
preuve que cette réouverture est
désormais loin d'être gagné en cas de
report ce serait un coup dur pour le
secteur évidemment déjà très touché par
les mesures de confinement de ces
derniers mois et plus généralement
l'instauration d'un troisième
confinement nationale pourrait avoir des
conséquences terribles pour l'économie
pas sûr que l'opinion soit aussi souple
que par le passé car il faut quand même
rappeler qu'actuellement nous sommes
déjà en parle de couvre-feu le
gouvernement devrait alors expliquer en
quoi la fermeture des commerces par
exemple s'imposent afin de réduire la
propagation du virus ces derniers jours
les chiffres de personnes testées
positives au coronavirus sont parfois
contesté la fiabilité de certains tests
antigénique est remise en question par
exemple le canard enchaîné révélait la
semaine dernière que ces tests donner
une proportion très élevée de faux
positifs de quoi jeter le doute sur les
chiffres quotidiens des contaminations
une chose est sûre l'impact des
festivités de noël sur les données
sanitaires sera cruciale crucial pardon
pour les décisions à venir alors que
certains élus locaux constatent une
forme de relâchement dans la population
appelé plus que jamais à ne pas célébrer
le passage à la nouvelle année
merci beaucoup thomas pour ces
précisions on suivra bien évidemment
tout cela de très près notamment le
conseil de défense demain matin sur rtl
france